sarah highland and wells adams wedding
was a modern family reunion we want all
the people that we love there and um we
both have very large families i have my
modern family on top of that which is a
very large group of people yep that
large modern family cast was there for
sarah's big day as she and the bachelor
in paradise star tied the knot in an
intimate ceremony in santa barbara
[Music]
sofia vergara shared several snaps of
the tv fam like this shot of julie bowen
sitting at the ceremony behind her and
her son manolo this sweet pic of jessie
tyler ferguson and his hubby justin
makita and this moment with nolan gould
and the cast also had some fun in the
photo booth it's been so amazing to be
part of the show i think we have made
people from everywhere in the world
laugh and you know love the show also
there ariel winter sarah's on screen
little sis god is she gonna sleep all
day long okay that coming from you the
possum's actually laughing justin shared
this shot with jesse nolan and ariel
posing outside the venue we've made
lifelong friends on this production so i
think that's what we're luckiest to have
sarah's modern family cast has been
there since the start of her and wells
relationship which began in 2017. at the
time she told et just like her real
family the tv fans gotta give their
stamp of approval it's almost like he
got it like for guys like you have to
meet the parents
which is stressful but then i think the
more stressful thing is to like meet
them
to meet like the second family which is
not only the dunphy family but the
entire cast and the entire crew and all
of our writers and everybody that's
involved like that's the second family
that is like i think the most terrifying
thing for guys that i date oh and
sarah's on screen mama julie was so
ready to meet her new boo sarah have you
introduced wells to them yet no no we're
waiting
we're waiting wells
right here in the dunphy living room
feel free to show up whenever you want
there's no doubt wells got the thumbs up
he popped the question just two years
later but the cobia 19 pandemic put
their wedding plans on hold but i mean
we had we had a very bare bones i really
wanted to focus on filming the last
season of modern family
and not kind of go into like my monica
geller crazy like wedding planning kind
of stuff that i know that i would have
gotten into and then been like oh wait
the show's over that was 11 years of my
life what happened fast forward a couple
years and sarah and wells were finally
able to say i do if i'm being honest
i've i kind of felt like we've been
married for for this entire time i mean
we live together we have dogs together
uh
you know like i go to the pharmacy to
like pick up like
her medication you know like like we do
marriage stuff you know
uh but i think it'll be nice to have all
the people that we love like uh
get to celebrate us you know
[Music]